Any time I tell people that I have 5 cats,
they all say the same thing:
"Oh wow.
Your house must smell."
Uh, no, cause..
[hallelujah]
I'm used to the way that people react
to how many cats I have,
and it's never really bothered me,
until recently.
So I had this really weird moment when
I was researching tortoise shell cats
and their "tortitudes", so cute,
when I read this article that said:
"Black cats are aloof, sometimes distant...
(ding)
Grey cats are very needy...
Tabbies are very friendly...
(ding)
Orange cats are cuddly...
and Tortoise shell cats are vocal, ill-tempered,
and like to boss around other cats.
(ding ding ding)
All of this is so spot on!
Oh my god.
Am I a crazy cat lady?
Wait no, I don't have a white cat.
Ooh, I need to get a white cat..
I've been called a crazy cat lady.
But am I one?
Hmm? Nn. Hmm?
(sweet music)
Aw, it's missing Ghost..
Here, come kitty! Here kitty kitty, come here kitty kitty!
Hi kitty kitty! (demonic) Hello kitty kitty..
And why is that such a bad thing? I mean, what is up
with the stigma against people who love kitties?
Cats are funny, they're cute, they're cuddly creatures..
and yet, people have a lot of negative things
to say about women who love them.
You're like, never gonna get married.
Oh wow, you must be so emotionally unstable..
Oh my god, why? Dogs are so much better.
If dogs are a man's best friend,
cats are a woman's bestie.
They were worshiped by ancient Egyptians,
they're the cornerstone of the internet.
They're the independent and elusive loves of our lives.
Am I a crazy cat lady?
No.
I'm just a cat lady.
But if anyone can't handle that..
tough kitty.
I'm Anna Akana.
Stay awesome Gotham.
I wanna say thank you to Tidy Cats
for sponsoring today's video,
I know! A match made in heaven
cannot be more purrrrrrrfect.
If you find that you have stank face from the
obnoxious odors of inferior kitty litters,
you must make the switch to Tidylock.
My kitty Lily, she's the oldest,
she's very particular about her litter
box and the kind of litter I use,
especially cause she shares her whole
bathroom area with 4 other roommates,
and she highly recommends it.
You can go to stopstankface.com to
learn more about Tidylock products.